alors j'ai découvert une étude on l'a
demandé aux français de donner une note
à leur physique
je vous jure que c'est vrai en moyenne
les français se mettent une note de 6,6
sur 10 ha en tant physiquement il dit
voilà moi tu h au dessus d'un moyenne
soit 6,6 sur dix les hommes se donnent
une note de 6,9 sur dix et les femmes un
peu moins qu'une moyenne de 6,4 servir
les dogues se trouve beaucoup plus beau
que les femmes voient l'allemagne ça
raconte un des hommes voilà on le savait
un petit peu mais la hausse est encore
plus alors la région où les gens se
trouvent le plus beau physiquement c'est
le grand test avec 7,1 sur dix voiliers
la vitesse et la région les gens se
trouve le moins beau c'est la bourgogne
franche comté alors qu'olic heures de
noter leur physique sur 10 mais aussi de
noter les autres personnes autour de la
table
alors je vous le dit eric naulleau vous
n'êtes ni combien il ya une seule
manière de se tirer de ce piège cette
semaine 5 vous avez mis 5
physiquement comme ça perce alors
l'attaqué 1,5 c'est la moyenne je vous
le dis les autres chroniqueurs vous ont
donné physiquement la moyenne de
regarder 4 4
[Applaudissements]
la meilleure note avoue et afin
d'affiner moyenne baisse sur brouiller
les gens je vais donner quand même deux
trois trucs c'est christine kelly avec
un 8 sur 10 avouent amitié retrouvée
très beau moi je retrouve qui dégage
quelque chose effectivement non c'est
juste une odeur à la voir il dégage est
vraiment génial a qui vont dégager votre
pire note
c'est jean-michel qui vous l'ami avec
1,2 et c'est très bien payé sa mission
moi ce qui m'aurait inquiété ce qui me
met indices ouais c'est vrai bon partout
je change donc vous êtes rassurés
j'estime qu'elle dit vous vous êtes mis
testing vous êtes mis 5 sur 10 tout est
ce que vous pensez
les chroniqueurs vous ont mis de moyenne
plus élevés ou moins élevés que votre
note perso moi je suis dit combien 7 6
si vous ont mis les autres chroniqueurs
6,6
votre meilleure note c'est kelly et
géraldine avec neuf sur dix est votre
pire note c'est gilles verdez qui vous a
mis quatre sur dix n'est pas mal non
mais attendez mais il fait de belles
entrées fonds sachez qu'il avait mis
deux anneaux l'oci en fait attention à
lui jean michel maire jean michel maire
il s'est mis 12
il s'est mis 8 sur 10
ces 8 sur 10 uniquement est-ce que vous
pensez que vous avez plus ou moins à moi
j'ai voulu élever alors moi laisse
commande et vous avez la moyenne non
sinon ellaone est regardée et la moyenne
donnée par les autres chroniqueurs
regarder
alors la meilleure note celle qui vous a
donné la meilleure note
je vous le dis c'est christiane et
géraldine 9 sur 10 ans un goûter
attendait faut pas nos clubs dans
quelque chose d'assumé tempes
grisonnantes une bedaine
on note que physique ouais bah oui bah
oui c'est un autre visage
le fait de s'assumer triche pas et
trichent pas et ben non il est beau et
est la pire note
sachez que c'est eric naulleau qui moule
amis
[Applaudissements]
je savais qu'il faudrait pas mettre zéro
la voix de moi vous êtes vous le trouvez
où vous vous trouvez au ride
pressé sur toulouse le moral que j'ai
jugé c'est sa distinction disent oui je
trouve que 0 temps avec y décède koala
et maxime d'une maxime guennic on met
ces données lui 8 il s'est mis cet
ennemi sur les dessous
elle vient du cran set et demi sur dix
c'est à dire qui se prend pour un grand
plèbe et aveugle maxime kenny moyenne
donnée par les autres est ce que vous
pensez que vous avez la moyenne on n'a
rien on est beaucoup moins de ce que
j'avais pensé à fils et demi cette voie
là voilà exactement six et demi cette
voie si la note donnée par les
chroniqueurs 4g
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la meilleure note a été donnée par
christine kelly alors l es sahel mais
tout cela lui a mis 9 sur 10 ans et non
attendez aux gars afin d'atteindre et
non plus grave la pire note à la danse
vos maxime des niches ne dit rien parce
que tu vas reproduise et là là là tu
clak là tu vas prendre une grosse
déception dans la gueule ah ouais nan la
pire note qu'il y ait kelly c 2 sur 10
c'est kenny quitte la gaule avec 2 sur
10 elle pensait pas que je savais qu'ils
allaient souhaite une bonne année mais
ce n'est pas tout justifier
l'oncle et le mal est fait la personne
est mal va déterminer ses blessés non
mais les gens et les attentions
oui mais je n'ai pas attention kelly
kelly s'est donné une note de 6 sur
l'avenir c'est honnête le boisé que
celle à luçon - c'est plus que ce soit +
6 9 qui sont belles non pas tous en même
temps j'espère votre meilleure note
vous avez eu un 10 sur 10 moan argent
ouais c'est jean michel maire qui vous
l'a mis un but finalement sur iphone
mais je la perds tu m'étonnes quoi
tu avais me disent tu fais quoi
il a tellement raison mais jamais dragué
genre ouais ouais bien sûr il ya des
lois
c'est quoi la démission et je vous le
dit votre pire note
ces quatre sur dix essais gilbert des
résultats de la mer vers la colonie ci
ne mérite que 2,4 gardons-nous gilles
verdez lund i et ma moyenne
ah oui votre moyenne c'est vrai vous
savez 8,36 ça va être la meilleure
moyenne sans plus alors non alors
attention
gilles verdez vous vous êtes mis vous
êtes noté m
on va d'abord voir la note donnée par
les autres les autres vont me et france
groupe c où parce que je vous le dis
vous êtes pris vous êtes dans béni oui
oui je suis surpris j'ai surpris parce
que votre note et elle est supérieure à
celle de nos lots supérieurs à jour du
jeu celle de jean-michel non oui une
erreur alors et non vous êtes vous êtes
à 4,9 sur dix ans
vous vous vous êtes noté physiquement
vous êtes mis un oui un prestigieux 1
il est votre meilleure note
c'est géraldine maillet qui vous l'a
mise 8 sur 10 pensent ils à un koné lord
anglais décadent ottawa des cahiers sur
la reçois des cadeaux tout à fait c'est
d'abord beaucoup de chats ouais moi j'ai
dans un film d'époque aux impôts mais
alors peut-être est la pire note
c'est quelqu'un qui vous a mis 0 il ya
quelqu'un qui qui a dit vraiment pour
moi c'est zéro ça ne vaut pas plus c'est
jean michel maire mais vrai bon alors à
tout chaud on va passer à isa tension de
tueur isa or ces commandes mais il a
quand même vous est donné aux femmes est
soumis quatre amis du quatre et demi sur
dix y passer la cataracte
si j'avais mis l'intérieur si je m'étais
si j'avais jugé l'intérieur 120,8 parce
qu'il est très bien entretenu mais selon
lui l'expérience
merci l'intérieur isiro put alors les
autres chroniqueurs la moyenne et ouais
vous êtes largement au dessus vous êtes
à 6,6
la meilleure note c'est kenny bel ovni
qui vous la donner avec 10 sur 10
elle est sympa mais bon voilà la raison
bonjour par systra choses auraient mis 7
ce que je trouve très belle voilà mes 10
et voilà c'est une benne à 3,7 une très
bonne note et gilles verdez alami la
pire note vous m 3 oui mais vous m'avez
dit non tu reviens tu es honnête avec
toi même franchement c'est généreux 3
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez on va passer à géraldine maillet
jeffrey battue de rome aux après parce
que ce soit chez un type qu'elle ferait
cela n'ayant donné c'est peut-être la
meilleure avait alors géraldine maillet
un mot vous êtes me 6,5 sur 10 classes
les autres vous ont donné une moyenne de
sa 7,1 points et la meilleure note
c'est toujours christine kelly avec dix
sur dix est votre pire note c'est
toujours gilles verdez 1 avec 3 suède
c'est l'école des fans n'ont pas jamais
un cast ipad bailleur n'est pas faux
alors benjamin castaldi les corps lui il
s'est mis 7 sur 10
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'ils se voient pas
forcément comme ça il est pas mal alors
il s'est mis sept sur dix castaldi bah
oui et je vous le dis la moyenne des
autres chroniqueurs
c'est bizarre il a pas une si mauvaise
note que ça vous étonne
oui oui des gens puissent maintenant
vous avez un cheveu sur la langue est
pour sa part fait ça alors là continuez
comme ça et c'est pas mal c'est qu'ils
apprennent personnes on continue comme
ça c'est bon quand il est comme ça tu
sais juste qu'il est bloqué du sahel à
voir avec un coup de pression alors et
les autres vous en donner une moyenne de
regarder castany à et enfin enfin vous
c'est ridicule parce que c'est hors
catégorie matthieu delormeau vraiment
être beau nature de leurs défauts que
les autres
j'ai eu plein matthieu lambeaux vous
vous êtes donné 9,1 matthieu delormeau
c'est pas midi un acte passé 40 ans me
suis relevé 0 seront je le dis je vous
le dit mathieu la meilleure note jusqu'à
présent c'était kelly avec comme elle
était quelqu'un qu'on méritait à 8,3
support saviez combien 8,9 jce elle s'en
fout eh bien peut-être vous est donnée
9,2 les autres chroniqueurs ont noté
votre physique aussi ouais
je pense qu'on a 1,9 géraldine et cette
date à 7,1 benjamin castaldi 5 7 et 10 8
6 matthieu delormeau je peux dire une
phrase avant mardi a précisé que à
vaincre sans péril on triomphe sans
gloire
regarde la gueule les autres c'est dur
parce que votre problème ça s'est passé
a changé ma note pas de problème et sans
rien mathieu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
que ce soit
j'aurais préféré sale con que ça
matthieu delormeau et j'avais un 10 sur
10 de moyenne
matthieu delormeau c'est qu'il est que
mu à revoir votre note vous la
découvrirez dans un instant à toute une
route
on a donné voilà y'a je vous le dis il
ya eu un sondage ou des français se sont
donné une note physique les français se
donnent en moyenne une note de 6,6 sur
10 physiquement et vos les hommes 6,9 et
les femmes 6,4
oui bah on est d'abord là bas on va
parler de matthieu delormeau parce que
matthieu delormeau il s'est mis une note
matthieu delormeau son mairie 9,2 sur 10
matthieu delormeau vous pensez que les
chroniqueurs vous ont bien peu près
cette note là matthieu delormeau sachez
que par exemple par germain castano et 5
7 sur 10 de moyenne
regardez votre moyen est très bien payé
maintenant vous avez 5,3 sur 10 et je
vais vous dire celle qui vous a donné
celle qui vous a donné la pire note
c'est kelly pedowitz lui mais de fait ne
faites pas vous lui avez donné 12 je
crois c'est kelly vdo v10 qui vous a
donné la pire erreur voilà que pour elle
jean soit maxime gainey voilà bah comme
ça vous savez tout mal et maintenant ça
fait pas marrer attend les blagues
makari a tous je m'en fous et pas sur le
physique j'adore voilà depuis qu'il a
essayé de piquer votre place je le
trouve moche mais mathieu voilà merci
comme moi je vous dis en vérité nous
serait donné 3
je la vérité
toi tu marches comme ça c'est comme si
la turquie dont vous êtes fou quoi je me
serais donné trois mètres ne connais
personne qui savent autant que vous et
bien adorer vous aimez bédié dragon si
je peux me permettre je connais personne
qui va venir aussi moins longtemps mais
les folles 7 9 7 me ferais c'est vrai
comme l'est de benghazi
c'est beau c'est beau mais parfois aussi
un bon voire très bon très bon allez on
ne méritait de sortir un petit bout